[Music]
the little misfortune came back, it has about
300 inhabitants at about 300,000 inhabitants, more or less,
we give it a thumbs up because the crop
is there, it's like a hole, being surrounded by
mountains, so it's crossed by the
Nervión River, and well, it's in the
Basque country in the  north of spain
i was born in the center of bilbao in
indautxu which is like the heart of the
city
[music]
legacy nation and for me it is
like a dream to be working here well of
course i miss the book but
professionally it is an opportunity  Well,
I did start working in infographics
in 1993 at the El Correo newspaper.
I spent about 14 years there and it was there that I learned
what infographics is, how to manage the
journalistic part, how to design graphics and,
above all, how to visually tell stories
with sculpture, I think.  which is the trademark of
my work people don't know that many
times there is a sculpture behind the
graphics that used those sculptures
to get information to make the
illustrations
then  I came up with the idea of making an il
ustration about Bilbao but what would
happen if that illustration would be like
mod
l of me doing that illustration I did
't think it was interesting it was like
nother like standing in front of the illus
rator when he is doing the work no an
that  It would be nice, not many painters have done it, it
is from Velázquez, which is
one of my favorites, to Norman Rockwell,
this idea of placing yourself as a spectator watch
ng the artist at work, and it seeme
to me that it was like something a little more intim
te, not like entering the a
tist's studio to get high.  in
the back and see what station
and well when they do the sketches
with pencil and paper and well working with
hannah the designer for the
page layout well the next thing is to
build it that sometimes is complicated
first you have to design the
characters in this case I designed
myself that with that I don't think it was
very complicated and then you have to
build everything and to build everything  do
you have to experiment I had never
built I don't know a box of
paints so you have to work
with different materials like wood
glass I
sculpted which is a synthetic material
you have to paint it it has to look
real so that's always
complicated and it's nice not to
experiment  and see how the model is being
built and then, of course, make
the illustration about Bilbao, which was
that kind
of profile of the city, not to mix
different emblematic buildings that
have value for me and that
can contribute something to the readers
starting from the left in the old part, the
old town and reaching the
modern part with the
guggenheim and different
buildings from this selection of buildings
in the center is the guggenheim because
I think that right now it is
perhaps the most emblematic building in  bilbao is not
the one that has regenerated the city or the
building of el tigre not that my grandfather
worked on it well a long time ago  os years
what I like most about the possibly
is
the size and how elegant it is I like
the buildings I like to walk I like the
shops and restaurants I think that
feeling that it is elegant one of the
things I miss about Bilbao is the
At the same time, food is very, very tasty, so
eat pinchos in a bar or eat in
a restaurant and above all pastries.
I really like the sweet pastries
of Bilbao, such as Carolina,
which is the typical cake of Bilbao that was
created there with  its cream
what I hope is that it continues to improve so
that it continues to be sure that we feel
proud of the city that people like it
when they arrive in the city I
think it is what we all
aspire to that it continues to improve
[Music]
no
[Music  ]